Current Procedural Terminology or CPT is a classification of
medical procedures maintained and updated annually by the American Medical Association.
Like ICD, it is required for virtually all reimbursement.
CPT code is divided into three categories.
Category 1 codes are five digit numbers for
widely performed procedures and are divided into sections for anaesthesiology,
surgery, radiology, pathology in clinical medicine, and medicine.
Category 2 codes are for the collection of quality and performance metrics,
and are four digits followed by an F.
Category 3 codes are also four digits followed by an I,
and are temporary to allow for new or experimental procedures.
Each code has a full, medium,
and short description as you can see here,
by the various levels of detail for naming a flu vaccination for different purposes.
Given its use in billing,
a CPT code may provide details necessary to determine the proper charge.
Here, codes for a psychotherapy visit indicate
the length of the visit and the amount a provider patient interaction.
That charge would be more or less depending on the code used.
Here are the factors that determine the code,
and hence the charge for an initial patient office visit.
Clearly, there is some subjectivity to the selection of the code.
CPT codes may appear to be simple,
but given their critical role in billing and subtleties such as we have discussed,
selection of the right code is important,
and billing personnel require training to code correctly.
The goal typically is to submit the largest,
but, hopefully, legitimate bill.